[Musique]
faire son épicerie en ligne ce n'est pas
nouveau mais faire son épicerie en ligne
zéro déchet c'est un phénomène qui se
développe l'idée c'est vraiment de
simplifier puis qu'on arrête de dire oh
non j'ai pas le temps
une personne de plus ce qui réduit
cambistes emballages avec des jeunes
marques parce que c'est un manga d'amis
tous c'est l'avenir en fait ça qui est
marrant c'est sûr c'est un service de
l'avenir
réduire ses déchets diminue et les
emballages est parfois difficile alors
que 60 % des emballages proviennent du
secteur alimentaire des épiciers en
ligne propose de nous faciliter la tâche
alors on a un pois chiche dans cet
entrepôt lorraine et sophie prépare des
commande d'épicerie pour des clients et
séchez cidre de pomme j'avais commencé à
réduire mes déchets et j'arrivais pas à
motiver mes amis et à ce maître zéro
déchet je me disais toujours ben on n'a
pas le temps folie dans plein de
commerces différents c'est lourd à
transporter j'ai pas assez de beaucoup
j'ai trop de beaucoup j'ai oublié mais
beaucoup finalement l'idée de beaucoup
beaucoup penser à ces vraiment simplifié
tout ça son idée faire un système de
consigne les aliments arrive en grande
quantité comme pour ses amants le tout
est transvider d'environ consignés et
tous les aliments sont ensuite vendus en
ligne sur le site internet
les bouteilles sont consignés 3 dollars
les bocaux sont consignés de dollars non
souhaite pas vous vendre des beaucoup on
souhaite que vous nous les retourner les
pauses on assainit rempli et livrer de
nouveau un service qui peut contribuer
au zéro déchet selon johanne labrecque
professeure en marketing alimentaire ces
différentes alternatives présentées de
façon écologique une vraie à la maison
dans des conteneurs
utilisant des apps permet de réduire ou
le sentiment de culpabilité à drac
individus consommateurs que parfois on
ressent lorsqu'on achète des produits
qui sont soit trop emballé dans des
contenants plastiques
si tu as une épicerie de vrac qui a à
côté chez toi tu vas y aller mais si
elle est à deux kilomètres de chez toi
tu vas pas y aller donc il essaie
vraiment de rendre ça accessible à tout
le monde par le biais de l'épicerie en
ligne puis de l'adif raison leur reine
quitte l'entrepôt dans une voiture
électrique pour livrer les commandes à
ses clients pendant ce temps simon lui
est vrai que ce roux livre à vélo
situé sur la rive sud il se rend
aujourd'hui jusqu'à montréal depuis deux
ans simon a développé son entreprise
d'épicerie internet tout est livré dans
des poches de tissus et transvider dans
les propres beaucoup du client chez le
client
tous mettent notamment en route qu'est
ce que vous avez acheté sur le serveur
est beaucoup trop de choses
la farine
c'est comme ça que ça se passe chez
chacun de vos clients
son époque price vivier ont fait ça du
tout montre ensuite ans qui m'a souvent
jeunes en slip stream zéro déchet mais
de logistique aussi de trento qui s'y
rendent tout fait que nos chaussures +5
finalement de commander en ligne le jour
de la livraison
je regarde c'est pas ma commande sur les
conséquences aussi d'encourager une
jeune entrepreneure ce serait chouette
les prix et quasiment complètement
quelques petits trucs que je vais aller
chercher dans des extraits du quartier
dans cet espace collaboratif
un autre jeune entrepreneur benoît met à
jour le site internet de sa nouvelle
entreprise il ya deux ans j'ai une
petite fille et un petit bébé ça fait
beaucoup déchets à la fois ça prend
beaucoup de temps
donc du coup je vis d'elle avoir quelque
chose qui pourrait être pratique et à la
fois éco responsable pour aider les gens
justement à pouvoir consommer de manière
éco responsable avec moins de moins de
temps
il a donc développé zeste et comme pour
la plupart des épiceries internet zéro
déchet le ferait surtout fait pour
l'instant d'aliments secs et liquides de
produits de soins personnels et ménagers
rencontre aller partout l'heure
essentiellement au québec alors c'est
sûr que bien quelques aliments qui sont
secs et qui sont importés mais ses
partenaires québécois qui va nous
rapporter ces produits-là donc par
exemple on parlait des beurs de noah
s'est transformée par les entreprises
qui à chaque boucle
dans l'ensemble les prix sont
sensiblement les mêmes et parfois plus
bas que dans une épicerie internet
traditionnelles s'ajoute naturellement
les frais de livraison selon la commande
la différence c'est que l'on ne trouve
pas toujours tout ce sont des produits
pour la plupart biologique et le coût va
favoriser donc des fournisseurs qui sont
locaux qui sont biologiques ou qui ont
des engagements environnementaux et
sociaux des coopératives ou des
entreprises où il ya des parts féminine
on favorise également les fournisseurs
qui vont reprendre leurs contenants on
est seulement rendu au début de cette
tendance là parce que les exigences
environnementales
ne feront qu'augmenter vers des
entreprises plus communautaire qui
offriront des alternatives les plus
responsables
donc les
les grands joueurs auront aussi à
s'adapter d'ailleurs aux états unis et
en france l'entreprise loupe s'est
associée à des chaînes et livres dans
des contenants réutilisables des
produits de grandes marques veille
marion on vient juste de livrer marion
qui habite juste ici et elle nous a
donné ce roi bocaux non plus chaque
vocale est consigné de dollars on va lui
envoyer un code promo pour sa prochaine
commande
si on se ramène à venir 50 ans et avec
la consigne pour les pays de l'est ont
commandé par téléphone puis s'était
livrée à domicile dont il ne faut voir
comment est-ce qu'on va être capable de
retourner
de façon efficace justement des
pratiques beaucoup plus responsable
s'est classé plus longtemps à vélo près
plus rentable et prépare une vente mais
ce quelles sont les valeurs que
d'environnement des propres lui
oui ça 3d est fort puissant ni des
étapes tout ça mais j'aime la façon que
c'est vraiment ça l'important c'est le
far aussi qu'on m'interdit de transvider
et l'âge est parti pour la prochaine
livraison
tu habites suis je fais quand même
quatre saisons très bien c'est encore
les balbutiements c'est un nouveau type
de solutions je pense que c'est un
retour en arrière ou oui mais c'est
l'avenir en fait ça qui est marrant on
peut pas juste vivre et épuiser les
ressources de la planète
actuellement les chiffres des déchets à
montréal ce quasiment 1 kg de déchets
par jour par habitant
ce calme énorme on peut faire des gestes
tous pour vraiment réduire ça
[Musique]